kanada mit luca und meine lieben freunde
in den letzten tagen war ich mal wieder
im internet unterwegs und habe mit den
ein oder anderen ebay kleinanzeigen
fällen rausgesucht die stadt allerdings
nicht direkt mit einem ebay fell sondern
mit einer zalando kundenbewertungen für
diese rose und zwar schreibt ein zalando
kunde mit diese hose durch den weltkrieg
den um diese hose werde ich zurück von
weltkrieg kommen ja einwander an bord
war unter dieser bewertung befindet sich
allerdings noch eine weitere bewertung
zugleich eine hose nur in grau und
verschreibt der zalando kunde ruft diese
hose jugendliche werden bruce lee sein
cousin walla diese hose du machst dein
bein höher als weiße haus von trapp am
tag all diese yoga magie alles klar
unter diesen beiden bewertungen befindet
sich dann eine weitere rezensionen wo
ein kunde allerdings einfach nur perfekt
schreibt allerdings befindet sich
darunter eine erneutem tonne zalando
kundenbewertung und verschreibt er
einfach zu wild die hose war trug mit
paar brüder niemand könnte klären außer
ich nur weil ich diese hose anhatte
kaufen direkt noch eine für miese zeiten
günstig habe babys wohl abbild ja meine
lieben freunde und ich würde sagen mit
diesen tollen zalando bewertungen kommen
wir nun auch zu einer tollen amazon
bewertung
ihr seht schon es geht um ein buch und
zwar schreibt er liebe heiko es ist ein
buch mit aneinandergereihten buchstaben
ab und zu werden diese durch ein
leerzeichen oder satin zeichen
unterbrochen dadurch ergibt sich ein
teilweise sinnvoller text dateien buch
so ansicht allerdings sollte er heute ja
nicht ausschließlich um irgendwelche
lustigen bewertungen gehen die im
internet gefunden habe sondern es geht
ja um ebay fällt es uns war hier um
einen ikea spiegel denen eine person für
15 euro verkauft sieht erstmal normalen
angebot aus wenn sich das bild dann
guckt ist immer noch ein komplett
normales angebot als nächstes verkauft
eine person ein ei phone 7 bei ebay
kleinanzeigen und er stellt das foto
hier rein
man denkt sie okay sie ist ein iphone
das er verkauft die produkt überschrift
ist wie verkaufen als 7 uhr 220 euro und
in der beschreibung steht verkaufen all
foren sieben top zustand der kratzer ein
jahre alt ja
ich wäre hätte nicht so ein alter von
sieben jahren mit einem kratzer der ein
jahre alt ist unter dem angebot von
diesem all phone 7 kam dann allerdings
eine frage von einem interessenten und
er schreibt hat das gerät whatsapp wenn
du die app im app store unterlegt was
ihr kostenlos ist hat es auch whatsapp
ich verkaufe das telefon auf
werkseinstellungen wo ist der nächste
app store
hey eine frage was ist die akku
kapazität und wie viel gewalt hat es
ja
ja beim nächsten ebay geht es darum dass
eine person ein boot kaufen möchte
dieses boot wurde allerdings schon
verkauft das möchte der potenzielle
käufer allerdings nicht wahrhaben von
einer schreibt der verkäufer hallo das
boot wurde heute verkauft mit
freundlichen grüßen hallo ich bin
unterwegs
das finde ich nicht gut was soll das
denn morgen bei ihnen
okay sie können gerne kommende mache ich
ihnen einen kaffee aber das boot ist
nicht mehr da leider fahre 450 kilometer
das brot ist nicht mehr da das klären
wir morgen auf den ersten blick erkennen
hier glaube ich nur die absoluten potter
heads was ihr verkauft wird
wenn man sich dann allerdings den titel
anschaut weiß so gut wie jeder was
gemeint ist um 21 aber starb aus dem
film harry potter wird hier für 15 euro
verkauft
hört sich alles komplett normal an das
lustige ist allerdings die
produktbeschreibung da steht nämlich er
ist von einem zauberer von haus
havelpark
ja
wie verhält sich das haus haselbach hier
geht es um ein wg-zimmer dass eine
person zum ersten acht und vermietet und
zwar schreibt darin interessent hallo
das thema wird ausschließlich an
weibliche vermietet liebe grüße hallo
ja warum weil meine mitbewohnerin dass
du möchtest deine mitbewohnerin beim
nächsten jetzt folgende mail fame wurde
das produkt bereits verkauft und
versendet und der verkäufer fragt dann
einfach mal freundlicherweise nach ist
das päckchen gut angekommen die
nachricht hier wurde zensiert weil dort
der name steht und die person antwortet
melde mich nachher dann viel später
schreibt der joh
alles toll angekommen danke dir
funktioniert einwandfrei ich werde mein
vater ich bin glücklich keine ahnung hab
ich das erzähle bin gerade heil schönen
abend noch
der nächste fall ist nicht direkt auf
ebay passiert sondern auf der website
will haben das ist aber quasi genau das
gleiche und zwar hat dort eine
verkäuferin namens martina in der
nachricht von herbert bekommen er
schreibt hallo martina das ist kein
problem
ich würde ihnen mit versand zwei eu
überweisende wäre das in ordnung für sie
liebe grüße und noch was sie sind wunder
wunderhübsch martin hat nicht
geantwortet und an herbert geschrieben
hallo marina sind sie sauer dass ich
ihnen ein kompliment gemacht habe also
nehme ich es zurück und sagen herzlich
mfg alles klar herr wert
ja alles klar herr weiß auf jeden fall
wie man mädels rumkriegt als nächstes
kommen wir wieder zu einem reinen meine
lieben freunde es hat euch an der
letzten folge lief es ganz gut gefallen
und zwar diesmal rose sind rote valletta
ist die hauptstadt von malta warum kauft
keiner diese scheiß rosen alter finde
goethe und die sollten vergessen werden
sondern du
wisst ihr verkauft jemand ein kaputtes
samsung handy und ich habe mir im ersten
moment gedacht als ich das bild gesehen
habe haye
er will das vielleicht verkaufen und
dann irgendwie für bastler dass die dann
vielleicht wieder reparieren können oder
so näher verkauft hat dinge als das
kleinste laptop der welt einzigartig für
100 euro
da hat sich samsung mal wieder etwas
spannendes einfallen lassen das passt
garantiert in jede hosentasche und liegt
in etwa so viel wie ein handy die
tastatur befindet sich übrigens auf der
gegenüberliegenden seite vom bildschirm
dass es sehr praktisch greift zu im
wahrsten sinne des wortes ja also das
ist wahnsinn vor allem dass sich die
tastatur auf der gegenüber liegenden
seite befindet ist halt hammer damit man
direkt sieht was man schreibt hier
verkauft jemand einen star wars 2
fighter ich habe jetzt nicht mega die
star wars ahnung aber das ist
anscheinend ein flugzeug allerdings hat
eine person auf ebay hier definitiv mehr
ahnung von star wars und rap tipp das
ist ein xvi ich weiß meine eltern sagten
wenn der iks swing nicht verkauft wird
kann ich ihn behalten deshalb falscher
name und so
10.000 bei mir ist nicht viel hab ich
wieder so eine person rausgesucht die
hier innerhalb von ein paar minuten
gegen die sein komplettes leben verpackt
hat ich meinen sieht einfach selbst er
schreibt sehr geehrte damen und herren
ich interessiere mich für die wohnung
ich bitte um nachsicht für eine
besichtigung mit freundlichen grüßen
hallo passt ihnen samstag um 12 uhr 30
mit freundlichen grüßen ok danke schön
aber ich bin jetzt arbeitslos tutorial
wie man innerhalb von sechs minuten
einfach mal arbeitslos wird beim
nächsten ebay weiß ich überhaupt nicht
was da gerade abgeht
aber seht einfach selbst vielleicht
können sie sie in der nähe des
überdachten aquariums fangen ich kann zu
dir nach hause kommen weil ich ein auto
sein werde bitte was es ist besser
fische zu fangen wenn das licht aus ist
was
ja ich bin leicht verwirrt hier sucht
eine person einen fahrer und der fahrer
fragt hallo wie viele kilometer sind es
insgesamt wars kilometer kommt sogar
deutsch schreibe ist gefährlich was will
man hat sich erledigt so jemanden möchte
ich nicht fahren
schönen abend noch karl oertl ferien
nicht gekommen
ich gebe die nur personen die auch wird
aus schreiben können du hilfsschüler ja
britisch genau wie dort sprachen lernen
da der nächstenliebe fälle gab es zuvor
eine preisverhandlung und jetzt schreibt
die person also ich habe mit meinem mann
gesprochen für 150 euro können sie sie
haben sie müssen aber zu zwei zur
abholung kommen da ich ihnen beim tragen
leider nicht helfen kann ich sage ihnen
morgen wenn ich sie sehen kann damit ich
in ein auto steigen kann
fragezeichen verstehe ich leider nicht
morgen werde ich dir sagen zu welcher
zeit ich sie schlagen werde
wie bitte
da schließe ich mich an wie bitte haye
ist das neues sofa noch to heaven gries
max leider ist das neiße sofort die weg
ich habe jobs vergessen die anzeige zu
die litern ich hoffe du findest noch
eine andere neiße sitz possibility um
deine base zu chillen futures scheiß das
ist geteilt worden ist danke für deine
ernster und meistens setzt die noch im
ebay & small screen gaming ebay small
screen game ist sicher das krass das
lustigste die beste die geil geil geil
geil
nun allerdings auch schon zum vorletzten
ebay für die heutige folge und zwar ist
es quasi einfach eine aneinanderreihung
von beleidigungen
hier wird ein samsung lcd tvs mit 55
zoll verkauft und ein potenzieller
käufer bzw interessant sagt das ist kein
55 zoll fernseher dürfte so ca 21,5 zoll
seien halt deine fresse das 55 selber du
vollpfosten geh mal weiter xl tragen du
cap wurde ist schon gemeldet die
lachnummer deine mutter warte ab ich
meld dich auch jetzt du ja dann geht
doch beide zu ebay petzen und kommen nun
auch schon meine lieben freunde zum
letzten ebay kleinanzeigen fällt für die
heutige episode und zwar ist es ein
extrem langer produkt beschreibungstext
über einen föhn
ich lasse euch einfach mal fort dieses
kraftpaket einem föhn zu nennen ist eine
beleidigung für dieses außergewöhnliche
gerät auf maximale stufe entwickelt
dieser haartrockner eine leistung die
einem zuverlässigen locken gerade zieht
die gesichtshaut und sämtliche mitesser
und pickel aus der visage kirche hat mit
entsprechenden verlängerungskabel
benutze ich diese maschine im herbst als
laubbläser mit leistungsstarken akkus
ausgestattet kann dieses ding problemlos
auch als strahlend triebwerk für moderne
düsenjets eingesetzt werden oder als
antriebsquelle für roller fahrräder oder
mittelschwere kampfpanzer durch die
kompakte bauform eignet sich dieses teil
auch hervorragend als ein lichtblick
halle abstand zwar vom einbrecher
hausierer und zeuge jehovas zuverlässig
vom eigenen grundstück zu fähigen man
sollte einen sicheren stand einnehmen
bevor man das gerät einschaltet um vom
rückstoß nicht aus den latschen gekippt
zu werden vorsicht ist geboten wenn sich
haare möbel oder kleinere pass
vier flugzeuge im anzug bereich dieses
films befinden die ansonsten eingezogen
und geschreddert werden können und an
der stelle wo ich das heute wieder dabei
wenn ihr freund weiter gefallen hat er
noch gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem
video er wollte einen neuen teil lieber
feldern streits auf jeden fall gerne die
bewertungen
[Musik]